DIRECTOR'S HELP.
PART TWO OF MY OPENING MONOLOGUE
IN JUST A MOMENT.
FIRST WE'RE JOINED BY FORMER
CONGRESSMAN TREY GOWDY.
LET'S GET YOUR REACTION NOW THAT
WE KNOW THAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL HAS IN FACT ASSIGNED
THIS U.S. ATTORNEY IN
CONNECTICUT TO REVIEW THE
ORIGINS OF THE RUSSIAN INQUIRY.
THAT AND WHAT OTHER QUESTIONS
WHAT YOU LIKE ANSWERED?
>> THIS IS THE FOURTH PERSON
CHARGED WITH INVESTIGATING THE
ORIGINS OF THE RUSSIA PROBE.
I'M MORE INTERESTED IN HOW
QUICKLY AND EFFECTIVELY THEY DO
IT MORE THAN THE NUMBERS.
IF THIS IS THE RIGHT PERSON TO
DO IT, MORE POWER TO THEM.
THERE'S AN EASY ROAD MAP TO
FOLLOW, SEAN.
WE KNOW THE ORIGINS OF THE
RUSSIA PROBE, WHAT THE RUSSIANS
DID US TO.
I WANT TO KNOW THE ORIGINS OF
WHEN THEY MINGLED THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN WITH THE RUSSIA PROBE.
YOU QUOTED LINDSEY GRAHAM THEY
WANT TO STOP TRUMP.
ALL HE WAS DOING WAS QUOTING
PETER STRZOK.
HOW DID THE FBI EVALUATE
CHRISTOPHER STEELE?
THEY HAVE THEIR OWN INTERNAL
DOCUMENTS.
I THINK YOU'LL BE SURPRISED AT
WHETHER OR NOT THEY VIEWED
STEELE AS BEING CREDIBLE --
>> Sean: THIS IS IN THE GANG OF
EIGHT INFORMATION, I'M TOLD, MY
SOURCES.
>> I SAW IT BEFORE I LEFT.
I KNOW JOHNNY RATCLIFFE HAS SEEN
IT.
I KNOW EXACTLY WHAT JOHNNY AND
LINDSAY ARE TALKING ABOUT.
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT INTERNAL
FBI DOCUMENTS WHERE THEY DID
THEIR OWN ASSESSMENT OF WHETHER
CHRIS STEELE WAS RELIABLE,
302s WHERE AN FBI INFORMANT
SAID HE'D DO ANYTHING IN THE
WORLD TO MAKE SURE DONALD TRUMP
LOST.
THAT WAS AN FBI INFORMANT BEFORE
THEY GOT RID OF HIM FOR BREAKING
FBI RULES.
>> Sean: ARE YOU CONVINCED THAT
FBI AGENTS, AS WELL AS THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AT THE TIME,
THAT THEY RIGGED HILLARY'S
INVESTIGATION?
>> I'M CONVINCED THAT THEY
HANDLED THAT INVESTIGATION IN A
WAY UNLIKE ANY INVESTIGATION I
HAVE EVER SEEN HANDLED BEFORE.
AND THE FACT THAT YOU STILL HAVE
TO ASK THAT QUESTION, SEAN,
AFTER A WHAT, 12-MONTH
INVESTIGATION BY THE WORLD'S
PREMIER LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY,
THE MEETING ON THE TARMAC, THE
FACT THAT COMEY HAD TO THREATEN
SPECIAL COUNSEL -- YOU MENTIONED
HE LEAKED MEMOS BECAUSE HE
WANTED A SPECIAL COUNSEL
APPOINTED FOR TRUMP.
WHAT DID HE DO WHEN HE HAD
QUESTIONS ABOUT LORETTA LYNCH?
DID YOU SEE HIM LEAK ANYTHING
THEN?
>> Sean: NOPE.
IF YOU HAVE TOP-SECRET
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION ON A
PRIVATE SERVER IS THAT NOT A
VIOLATION OF THE ESPIONAGE ACT?
>> IF HANDLED NEGLIGENTLY.
>> Sean: WELL, WE KNOW IT WAS
HANDLED NEGLIGENTLY.
WHAT IF YOU ACID WASH YOUR HARD
DRIVE, BUST UP YOUR DEVICES WITH
HAMMERS, PULL OUT SIM CARDS,
WOULD THAT BE A GOOD CASE FOR
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE, CLEAR
AND CONVINCING CASE, ONE BEYOND
ANY REASONABLE DOUBT?
>> IT IS FANTASTIC EVIDENCE ON
THE ISSUE OF INTENT, WHICH IS
WHAT COMEY SAID HE DIDN'T HAVE.
IT IS CONSCIOUSNESS OF
WRONGDOING.
IT IS KNOWLEDGE, ALL OF THAT, IN
ADDITION TO THE MULTIPLE
MISSTATEMENTS DEMONSTRABLY FALSE
STATEMENTS SHE MADE ABOUT HER
HANDLING OF IT.
>> Sean: ARE YOU CONVINCED THERE
WAS A FRAUD COMMITTED AGAINST
THE FISA COURT, AND IN FACT THE
BULK OF EVIDENCE WAS
UNVERIFIABLE, THEY NEVER
VERIFIED ANYTHING STEELE WROTE
WAS TRUE, AND THEY DID IT TO SPY
ON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN, SIR?
>> SEAN, I CAN TELL YOU IT IS
EVEN WORSE THAN WHAT YOU
DESCRIBED.
IT IS WHAT YOU DESCRIBED, IN
ADDITION TO THE WITH HOEDING OF
EXCULPATORY INFORMATION.
THEY MADE NO EFFORT TO
CORROBORATE THE DOSSIER UNTIL
AFTER IT HAD BEEN USED IN THE
APPLICATION AND RENEWAL.
NOT TO THEY FAILED.
HE THIS MADE NO EFFORT.
>> Sean: ARE YOU CONVINCED THAT
PHONY RUSSIAN DOSSIER BOUGHT BY
HILLARY CLINTON, CREATED BY
STEELE, THAT THEY LIED TO TO THE
FISA COURT, DID THEY TRY TO TAKE
A DUAL ELECTED PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES?
>> I'M JUST GOING BASED ON WHAT
PETER STRZOK SAID.
HE THOUGHT HE'D BE THE ELITE
AGENT IN CHARGE OF INVESTIGATING
THIS, SAID HE THOUGHT TRUMP
WOULD BE DESTABILIZING, HAD AN